the Florida Keys are virtually empty as
Erma moves closer hurricane and storm
surge warnings are in effect and
mandatory evacuation orders are in place
at least 31,000 people have already left
this string of tropical islands is about
a hundred and twenty miles long and on
average they're only about six feet
above sea level in the keys irma could
bring one to six feet at least of
flooding to the islands Elaine Quijano
is in Key Largo Elaine good morning to
you good morning to you Jeff as you said
most of the Florida Keys look like a
ghost town I want to show you what it
looks like right now here in Key Largo
very little activity what we have seen
in this house behind me people bringing
in that furniture making final
preparations basically as this storm
approaches next to that though house is
empty boarded up next to that house is
empty boarded up these boat slips here
empty those boats are pulled from the
water and those boats that do remain
here you can see they've tied them up
and tried to secure them as best they
can
now throughout Key West businesses are
closed and boarded up as well the court
of Key West is going to officially close
at 8 a.m. the three main hospitals in
the keys are also closed patients there
have been evacuated not everyone though
is getting out we spoke to some
fishermen here in Key Largo who plan on
staying and riding out the storm they
tied their vessels to the mangroves they
are hoping and praying that they will be
able to preserve those boats because
those boats are their livelihoods now
while some people are staying we
actually will not be staying here much
longer that's because we have been told
by the Monroe County Sheriff's Office
that as soon as these winds pick up just
a little bit they're going to shut down
access to the bridge the only way in and
out route 1 is going to be cut off Jeff
Elaine thank you very much